The answer is 10x cubed
y + 3xy cubed + 20xy.
This one was a bit trickier.
Let's see how we combine the like terms.
Well first we see that 3x cubed y and
7x cubed y are like terms.
And 9xy and 11xy are like terms.
Let's rearrange things so that our
common terms are next to each other
remembering that we can rearrange like
this because addition is commutative.
So after some rearranging we
get 3x cubed y plus 7x cubed y
plus 3xy cubed + 9xy + 11xy.
Now we can combine the coefficients of
the like terms, 3x cubed y + 7x cubed
y becomes 10x cubed y, 3xy cubed did
not have any other like terms to combine
with so we just keep it how it is.
And then we combine 9xy and
11xy to get 20xy.
And this is our final answer.